You are listening to
radiolab radio from W N Y.
S t. A. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab.
So we got an email from you
not long ago, our editor,
Soren Wheeler and I,
we got into a conversation with this
woman. I live in Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
Her name is Janell. Jenny. I like
the packers. Of course you do. Yeah,
I guess photographer would
technically be my job,
but I do a whole lot of different things.
None of which really pertain to
the story at hand. But that's,
and our story really starts when Janell
sent an email to the radio lab, um,
inbox basically saying,
I need your help. Yeah.
Something had happened to her that was
kind of wondrous and unexplainable and
very weird. And as a result,
Jenelle had found
herself stuck in a story,
a story told to hundreds of thousands
of people all across the [inaudible]
a story that sits right smack dab in the
middle of one of the biggest cultural
divides in our country right now.
It was a story that wasn't hers and
she wanted us to help her find a way to
finally tell her story, so to speak. Um,
do you want me to kind of just
talk me out? Yeah, sure. Well, um,
when I was 18, I went to a concert,
a rock concert actually is that warp tour.
So it's like a festival
of young rock concerts,
tons of bands on different stages
all over the place. And Janell
is walking around between
all the different stages
and merchandise tables when
she sees this 10 10 by 10 white 10th
with just the little table in front of a
table with a sign on it that said
bone marrow donor sign up to be on the
registry, save a life,
something like that.
So this was a rock music and good
deeds brought together, right,
which is a pretty good mix in hindsight.
So Jenelle read the sign and she
thought to herself, I'll sign it. Sure,
why not? Yeah. Did you know
what bone marrow was? Yeah,
yeah. I mean,
I knew that that would mean that they'd
take a really long needle and stick it
in you and suck out bone stuff. Yeah.
I suppose at that point that was
probably not the four thoughts. Um,
I think the altruistic
like do something. Yeah,
that was probably the main motivation
and all Janell had to do with standing in
front of that tent was signed
some papers and swab or cheek,
because with a bone marrow donation they
actually have to figure out if you're a
genetic match with someone who
would receive the donation. Yeah.
Which was part of what Jenelle thought
was cool about it. I always thought that,
you know,
just be an amazing opportunity to be the
one person who could do something for
somebody that like literally no one
else in the world could deep kind of
connection with someone there.
Yeah. There's, you know,
I don't know if either of you are
only children, but it's, yeah, it's,
you know how there's just like, you
have cousins, you've got friends,
but at some point there's
not that it sounds so stupid,
but that biological connection like
besides my parents or one night, right.
Was that, that you,
you missed the idea of someone who was
much Li like you and muchly in your world
and muchly
yeah.
And also even the kind of the need like
somebody out there dependent on me on
kind of that almost other worldly level.
So Janell swapped her
cheek, signed the paper,
and then went about her normal life.
And then about six months
later she got a call.
Yeah. Yeah. It was a phone call to
my landline. That's my along with,
oh gosh. So what year
are we talking here? No,
it's 2009. Okay. Um,
it was a phone call and I
remember very specifically,
it was a voicemail because I
hadn't had the chance to answer it.
And they said something to the extent
of, you know, high are familiar.
The national bone marrow donor registry.
We've done some tests and we've narrowed
you down to be a preliminary match for
a patient.
So we need you to come in and do some
further tests that involve no blood and
stuff. Did you think, oh no, I forgot
that I did that or are you thinking,
oh boy, or what were you, oh, I
was so I overcome with emotion.
I remember just just to
think there's somebody,
there's somebody out there
that might be my person. Uh,
so absolutely no hesitation
on my end. I went, sure.
Janell has into the clinic
because, well, some bone marrow,
the stuff in the kind of core of your
bones actually produces all your blood
cells and importantly including
um, your white blood cells,
which are a key part
of your immune system.
So what you're doing with the bone marrow
transplant is taking a healthy immune
system out of one person and putting it
into another person whose immune system
is, you know, cancer or, or
messed up in some kind of way.
He is though,
because the immune system is that part
of you that like recognizes you from not
you and attacks anything that's not you.
You have to like fool the new body into
thinking that this immune system is
them. And so the parts of your DNA that
have to do with your immune system,
couple of key parts of that
have to match with the donor.
So that's what they're doing with Jenelle.
They're taking her into like test your
DNA to see if the stuff that marks out
her immune system matches closely
enough with this, you know,
recipient so that the bone
marrow transplant will work.
And then maybe a month later I
get like another call on this one.
I was able to answer and they say, well,
we've done tests and you are the ideal
person in this 8 million person registry
to donate for this patient.
You are a perfect wow. Well you do it.
And I was like, absolutely. Um,
so did that feel totally like the
call of destiny? Like oh maybe,
maybe this was meant to be okay. Yeah,
there's something I feel
that's like bigger than myself.
That's happening and I
don't really, they made it,
can't really explain it yet at that
point. But I know there's like, okay,
here's a, there's a big thing.
So I go in and unfortunately
to disappoint you Robert,
the way that I don't need it,
bone marrow wasn't the actually the
real bad way with the big needle.
I'm no, I'm your new map disappointment.
Whoever have they come up with
a small needle urge. Yeah.
Well what the straw or something.
What they essentially do,
and this is actually the far
more common way of doing it,
neuro is they inject you with all these
drugs and it is like eight injections,
um, that boosts your white blood cell
count up to astronomical heights.
And do you know, like when you get sick,
when your immune system kicks
in overdrive and you feel sick,
imagine that like eight times over.
But just cause I [inaudible] Achy,
so achy, every bone hurt.
And while Janell was feeling
achy and sick inside of her,
her bone marrow is pumping out a bunch
of new baby blood cells on matured stem
cells that can really
become almost anything.
Then they just go in and [inaudible]
grab those cells. They harvest you,
I guess.
So you have a needle in both arms and
you pretty much sit still for six hours.
Jellies, suck all your
blood out of your body,
put it in a machine and give
you back what they don't need.
So I think they've got about, you know,
one of those little ivy begs just a
quart size plastic bag full of my stem
cells.
And once you're done they put some
bandaids on you and they're like, alright,
um, let us know if you need anything.
And do you know anything about like
what happens to your blood cells?
Like who gets it or what they're,
um, the whole, uh, registry is very,
very strict about patient confidentiality.
But they did tell me that it was, um,
a 29 year old man with acute lymphoblastic
leukemia and that's their like,
literally, that's all I knew for a
whole year. Did you look that up in the,
in the, Oh,
of course they did endless Google
searches of 29 year old man,
acute lymphoblastic leukemia, trying
to get a real p right. I was like, oh,
maybe he's worded it that way and
I didn't find anything of course.
But once the ears up, if both
parties agree, then we can talk.
And that's,
that's kind of really interesting because
I definitely was looking forward to
that year mark. But once that
hit, I kind of got cold feet.
I really just wasn't ready
to know exactly who he was.
Um, and then I was also worried that
maybe this guy's like real piece of crap.
Like maybe he's a clan member
or criminal or something.
So there's a part of that two or three
that you'd open up the sentinel and it
would say formerly ill person robs
three banks and hits all ladies.
Horrible man saved by Janell
Janney it's so stupid to say,
but I thought that,
so I did end up eventually
sending this email or whatnot in,
I think about October.
It took them a couple of weeks to actually
give my info to my patient and vice
versa.
I was eating a lunch with a friend of
mine and I remember having chips and
Guacamole
by the way. My, my patient's name
is Jim. Um, so they gave Jim my info
and my phone went off in my pocket.
There was an email in my inbox and um,
there was a,
a scanned pdf attached to this email and
open it up and she had filled this out
with their own hand and I just
broke, I totally badges a web,
like a little baby in a, in a
booth, in a Mexican restaurant,
middle of Grapevine, Texas.
Um, and I got on Facebook,
I saw a picture, I saw a picture of her
and I was like, oh my gosh, it's got,
it's kind of be her.
I had gotten an email or not email to
Facebook friend request from said this guy
named Jim Monroe in Texas.
And I was like, oh, okay.
I don't know anybody in Texas. And
then it clicked all the time. Ah, this,
this is the guy, this is him. I
could see his picture. I can look in.
What does he look like?
Not very much like me.
Better now with shorter, no, wait. Yeah,
I'm tall before I've got
blonde, her hair, blonde hair,
I think fake blonde, I should
say. It's started right now,
but I have like strawberry blonde
hair, but tall blonde haired,
blue eyed white guy. Um,
I'm very handsome. Yeah.
Short blonde haired blue
eyed person until I guess
we could be cousins. I think it, yes,
when I looked at all of his pictures and
his wife who's a model and these kids
were so adorable and he tried to find
as much as I can and as far as his
profession, I was like, oh, he
appears to be some sort of magician.
So I guess we'll talk about that leader.
So I don't even know, like,
I guess why don't we just find
out like where you're from,
where you were raised and okay.
That way. So I was, uh, born
in Orange County, California,
Fullerton, California. I went to school
in Anaheim, high school in Anaheim, uh,
was a baseball player. So I
ended up going, it was very,
very good baseball player. I,
uh, I got drafted by the, uh,
at the time they were called
the Tampa Bay devil rays.
Now they're just the Tampa Bay
rays. Oh, you were that good? Yeah.
I turned down a professional baseball
contract to go play at the University of
Texas in Austin. What did
you play? I was a pitcher.
I was a hard throwing right-hander huh.
And uh, ended up getting, like I said,
drafted and went to the University of
Texas to play baseball and that's what I
thought I was going to be.
I thought it was gonna be professional
baseball player. And then my, uh,
my sophomore year of college,
I blew out my shoulder.
I had a surgery my freshman year and then
came back and was throwing harder than
ever then did it again. Uh,
so baseball was kind of over,
I'm over it like 19, like that's,
yes sir. Yeah, it was a pretty,
it was a big kick in the head,
but he finished up school. They,
I maintained my scholarship as a medical
red shirt and majored in business and
psychology. Yeah. Then moved
up to boulder, Colorado,
got married and had a couple kids and
one of my really good friends during this
time was, his name was Tennyson and he
became one of my best friends and he was,
he wasn't just my best friend, he was
like my brother, he was an athlete too,
so he was a former college football
player and he had also lost his football
career based upon an injury.
Um, and then also new magic, uh,
and illusion and magic was actually
something that Jim had been fascinated by,
um, ever since he was a kid. Yeah.
I saw a trade show magician
when I was 10 or 11.
It was at the Anaheim convention
center of all places at an optometric
convention. Both of my parents are
optometrists and he was just doing
trade show stuff at a booth. Do
you remember what he was doing?
He did a version of this trick called
cards across. He made a cigarette,
appeared you gotta which he pulled out
of your head or out of somebody. Just,
he just casually holding his hand and
was holding a zigzag in the tips of his
fingers and he goes to light it and
there's a puff of smoke and there's a,
there's a real cigarette [inaudible] and
the thought you had at that moment was
I want to do that.
It was how did he do that?
And that is cool and you know,
I'm going to go learn how that's done.
So I just began to look at card tricks
and read books on all how all this stuff
was done to figure out how it was
done. So when he met Tennyson,
they started practicing together and
doing shows in front of friends and family
and pretty soon, sure
enough we start doing gigs.
But they started doing these shows at
like schools and festivals and stuff.
And they would do these tricks like a
lot of kind of card tricks and number
tricks. Say we pick a random
number and it went and up,
it was written on a piece of paper
in the shoe of an audience member or
something like that.
But then the show would turn into
something else because the thing is,
Tennyson was a believer overwhelmingly
so like believer like in God you mean?
Yeah. Uh, Christian and, uh,
Tennyson was very convinced and so
after an hour or so of magic tricks,
just pure entertainment, Tennyson would
say to the crowd. This has been great.
We're going to take a quick break.
We're going to give you guys a chance
to take off cause during the second part
of this show and we're going to talk about
what the Christian perspective is and
why we believe this Christian thing.
If you want to stick around, great.
If you don't take off. Now, Jim
says during this part of the show,
Tennyson in particularly was way more
of the evangelistic piece. This, um,
and I considered myself
more of a producer.
Now Jim had actually grown up
going to church. Yes, I was, uh,
my parents went to Lutheran church. I
was, um, at one point doing that. It's,
but still there's, you know, at
the end of the day it was just,
there was nothing in it that,
uh, seem to be satisfying.
And so at this point in the show,
Jim would sort of stand back a bit
as Tennyson talked about how magic is
actually all about the unseen
and behind the veil of reality.
There's a god watching over us and Jim
says he would be standing there on stage
watching these people in the audience
who are feeling this real connection with
God. However, um, I wasn't having
that experience. He's just like,
I don't feel what they're feeling.
And he started to think to himself,
I didn't want to be the
guy that said, well,
I'm a Christian because my
friends were, or I'm a Christian,
cause I was raised that
way. I want it to be true.
And he just wasn't sure that it was
right. Um, and then after he and Tennyson,
who had been doing this show for a
year and a half or so, Jim got a call.
Tennyson had been out
hiking in the mountains just
outside of boulder. And, uh,
he was found, uh, in a river.
His body was partially submerged,
uh, just at the edge of the water, at
the base of a 40 foot cliff. And, uh,
peaceful valley who was calling. No
one really knows how he passed away.
It looked like he might've
actually fallen from the cliff. Um,
the police thought maybe suicide,
but it could be, you know,
exposure to the elements,
that kind of thing. Um, yeah,
Jim says he was just, you know,
devastated and he's probably the
closest male friend I've ever had.
Just felt like he was, you know,
in the bottom of a hole. Yeah.
Bottom of a hole, kind of figuring
it out. Best friend passes away.
My wife and I as a result, Kinda got
into this really strange season where,
you know, I'm depressed, she's depressed,
we're pretty much on the verge of
calling it quits. Uh, and then, uh,
my leg starts hurting really badly.
We're in the leg underneath my right knee.
Jim says he started popping Advil
every day at first, just a couple,
then more and more. And
I'm trying to gut it out.
Then he came home one day and he says
the pain was so bad he couldn't even get
out of his car. And so
his wife was like, look,
we're going to the hospital now and I'm
sitting there and in an emergency room
and this man walks into my room
and he looks at me. He says, um,
you have cancer. Jim had leukemia,
which is I'm cancer of the blood cells.
So the white blood cells inside of your
bone marrow have literally exploded out
of control. And the reason why your
leg hurts so bad is cause your,
your bone is breaking on its own from
the inside. Wow. And he said, uh,
if you don't do anything, you're
going to die in two months.
Just before Christmas of 2008 Jim checks
into the hospital and right away they
do two things. One,
they put Jim on the bone marrow registry
in the hopes that he can find a donor
and two, just to keep
them alive, only waits.
They start putting him through round
after round of Chemo and get this wicked
concoction of stuff and then
be let out. He loses his hair,
his body starts to fall apart. And
all you can do at that point is just
hope, you know, like tick tock, tick tock,
tick, tick, Tock, tick tock.
That's when you think you know what
you believe to be true is in con is in
adversity. That's, that's when you
find out. And so for me it was not,
it was not a Christian worldview.
If there is an all loving on that,
a powerful being that makes
the universe go around,
then why would things like, you know,
suicide or murder or
rape exist in a, in a,
in this constructed world of his gym,
just couldn't get himself to believe
in the existence of a god like that or
really any god, no, there wasn't any
rhyme or reason or purpose is just,
this is, this is my
lot, this really sucks.
And then when he was at his lowest point,
I remember driving back to Houston,
Texas for more chemo.
And my phone rang and I didn't
recognize the number and I said hello,
and this woman on the other line,
she said, uh,
there's a one person that we've
been able to identify on the planet.
Out of all the databases,
everything, there's one,
you are the ideal person in this 8
million person registry to donate for this
patient. A thing about
that is in the world,
you are a perfect match, will you do it?
And I was like, absolutely.
My wife and I were in the car together
and it was just tears, you know,
it's like, wow, that's amazing.
So April 20th and this
is important to remember,
April 20th was when I donated
and is there a pulling the cells out
of Janelle's body up in Wisconsin?
You know,
one of those little ivy bags full
of my stem cells down in Texas.
Jim's doctors were telling him,
your bone marrow transplant is scheduled
for April 23rd on April 23rd the
nurses, they come inside of your
room to celebrate your second birth.
And then I remember Dr Dror telling me,
are you ready to put your
boxing gloves on? Well,
when he was preparing me for was a death,
come to find out later on they pulled
my wife out of my room and they said,
we're going to give this to Anne
with all this medication. He's,
he could potentially receive this and
reject this violently and pass away.
Because remember they're
essentially replacing Jim's
immune system with somebody
else's, in this case, Janelle's.
And in a very real way,
the replacing that part of Jim that
determines who he is with someone who he
clearly isn't.
And so there's a real chance the
body will just short circuit.
So they give you this drug and the
nurses nicknamed shake and bake.
It's designed to basically wipe out
whatever is left of Jim's immune system,
his, his white blood cells,
but inside a Viv and your
body just starts convulsing.
And then they put Janelle's
cells in and they monitored me.
And over the next couple of weeks
to know cells entered Jim's body,
they get into his bone marrow and they
start producing new white blood cells as
per basically producing a
whole new immune system.
And eventually Jim is cancer free. I mean,
it's literally like new life, you know.
Now I will say this, some bells kind of
began to go off on my head a little bit.
Jim says before he even
got the transplant, um,
his doctor had come into
his room and told him,
you're going to be like a baby
inside your mother's womb,
literally being born again because
on April 23rd and once again,
this is their terminology.
There's someone else that's going
to be living on the inside of you.
And this new system of blood is gonna
be your life. Why is that interesting?
You know, April 23rd,
my new birthday is April 23rd and
my old birthday is April 20th. Uh,
my new birthday is on April 23rd that's
on the third day. And on the third day,
significant cause of the biblical
echo of Biblical Echo. Yeah.
I came back from whatever I was in
because of the only blood on planet earth
that could save me and
my disease. So, you know,
does this land on you
the way it sounds to me,
like it lands on you now or did you
go through a like, like what happened?
Like those words. Yeah,
those words in particularly
bells went off in my head. Right.
Does that mean that you now suddenly, um,
believe in God again or for the first
time or, I mean, I, it's process, right?
You follow and then I think the puzzle
pieces are kind of all swirling and
coming together, but everything
changed on that demarcating day,
April 23rd, all thanks.
Obviously to Janell.
And not long after they got each other's
information and [inaudible] each other
on Facebook, they hopped
on a, on a phone call.
So she gets on and I get on
and, but it's all kind of like,
hey, oh my gosh, this is crazy. Yeah.
I cannot believe this is nuts. Yeah.
This is so crazy. And then she
drops this on me. She said,
I went and got a tattoo of a jigsaw
puzzle piece on the very spot where they
stuck that IV in my arm to pull out the
new blood knowing that I was the missing
piece in someone else's life and without
me, that person wouldn't be alive.
And I said, do you? I was like, I was
thinking, do you have a ton of tattoos?
And she said, no, I have one.
Do you know what Christians and related
to be true, right? What is that?
Their savior rolled up and showed them
the very spot on his body where blood
came out so that they would believe,
so you're just going down this
road, you're, you're just,
you're driving like a hundred miles
an hour towards, towards this. For me,
it was like I was being
introduced to a person.
Um,
there was an experiential understanding
of [inaudible]
that which was going on behind the scenes
of this existence that was answering
my [inaudible]
prayer. The prayer is for, is the
periods closed. Are you there?
Yep. Are you there? God
Basically Jim Satya now and her
donation to him as almost more than just
allegory is like something close to
literal proof of the existence of God.
Like a very real, very
present sign. I told her too,
I told her that we need to meet. I said,
can I please bring you out to Dallas,
Texas? He said, I have to bring you
to Texas, which is my nightmare.
I'm just kidding. Absolutely.
I wanted to go right into it.
I remember her tone. She's
like, yeah, sure. Super excited.
So yes, I flew her to Dallas, Texas.
This says Michael Scam rags and it's
coming down. I actually recorded it.
So it might be, you've met sqirl
girl saved my life. Oh really?
In the video you see Jim sort of standing
at the bottom of this escalator in
Dallas, Fort Worth
airport. He's, you know,
looking pretty thin and pale and nervous.
And then the camera
turns and there's Janell
coming down the escalator
and the hug, his kids come up,
his wife.
Okay, so, so, so now you'd go home.
We go to his, his home. Right.
And he lives in a very big
house outside of Dallas.
They had dinner with the
family and then, you know,
once everybody else was kind
of heading off to bed, um,
Jim and Chanel started to talk
and, uh, I think if I remember correctly,
we were just outside by the pool and
just talking and figuring out who each
other was and you know, I was
like, so, you know, magician,
what, what, what is that? And uh,
he started telling me about what kind
of magician he really is and he is a
Christian magician.
I'm sure that in her mind
she's thinking, oh my gosh,
I just saved a Christian
magician from Texas life
and jokes on me. Isn't
that wonderful? You know,
when we come back, Jenelle becomes
Jim's greatest magic trick,
so don't go away.
Drew Downey from Daphne, Alabama.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
[inaudible]
I'm former US attorney Preet Bharara.
Since I was fired by
Donald Trump last spring.
I've had time for a lot of new things
like hosting a special evening at the
Skirball center on Monday, December 11th
it's a live taping of my new podcast.
Stay tuned from [inaudible]
studios and cafe.
My guest will be the
daily show comedian Assan.
Manoj tickets are on sale
now at cafe.com/premium
okay, we're back. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab and uh,
okay, let's return to a story
from Soren Wheeler. So Soren,
you left us in the backyard. They
were about to talk, right? Yup.
Sitting in Jim's backyard by the pool
and he's basically telling her his whole
story about his sort of loss of faith and
the cancer and how she saved his life.
And then he tells her that
right after she saved him,
he started doing the magic show again.
That show that he used to do
with Tennyson is called the nays.
My name is Jim Monroe. This is the maze.
So we actually get to see Jim show
and I have to say he's a pro. It's a,
it's an impressive production.
He gets big venues here,
ready to have some fun tonight,
usually a thousand people or so.
There's crazy laser light show stuff
and he does these really complicated
illusions that are sort of half
Penn and teller, half David Blaine
sample taking a random phone number out
of the phone book where seven Zeros ends
up being someone in the audience and
then their phone will end up like hidden
somewhere, something like
that. And they're very good.
So Jim is telling Jenelle about
all these tricks, but then he says,
second half of the show is about us.
[inaudible] he explains it,
the magic show at this point.
And he tells people they can leave if
they want to and he starts to talk openly,
professionally to the audience.
Well, I quickly found
out that I had cancer
in very personal terms
about what happened to them.
Well my wife and I raced down
to MD Anderson Cancer Center
in a certain point he shows a video
stuff started cause I changed
anything in there. He's in
the hospital [inaudible]
throwing up into a bucket
and he's Pale, thin,
huge circles under his eyes.
And then he explains it right when he
was on the edge of death at his lowest
point, this, this thing
happened, a miracle happened.
There is one person just
when his blood was literally
poisoning his own body,
somebody substituted their blood on
his behalf so he could be born again.
Yes,
on your behalf that you can live again.
Read days after his birthday.
The third day I came back from the
dead is the only global appointment.
They're considered legacies.
So there's a whole three days thing there,
which is a story of Easter and
the rebirth. It's just, let's see,
I mean he sees this as like
definitive proof that there's a god
I didn't either.
The statistical anomaly that continues
to propagate this false ideology about
supernaturalism and miracle results.
I even got to the testicle
anomaly that the soul, the wild,
that's like being bitten by a shark and
struck by lightning at the same time
twice in this lifetime.
Or you might have to believe what I
believe is true and that is there is a
bigger one on mine, the
scenes and his name is Jesus.
Mm.
So yes, this is all being
thrown at me. And is he,
is he saying all this to
you by the pool? Is it all,
it all comes tumbling out.
Yeah. Yeah. And how are you,
how are you feeling inside stranger
and stranger going down the wormhole?
Because
I am an atheist in the sense that I don't,
I don't believe in the
tenants of Christianity.
I don't believe really in the tenants
of any established religion I've ever
seen. Honestly.
I just think that once things are
labeled and you're pigeonholed and the
exclusivity of really any religion is
this the cause for a lot of problems
throughout history.
But faith can be beautiful and there's
definitely parts of me and there's
moments in my life that boy praying and
really feeling like that was going out
to somebody would feel
great, but I just can't,
they just can't do it.
So at that moment he's
telling me this and yeah.
And he's like, well, you know,
you're here in Texas for this weekend
and would you be willing to come on stage
for one of my shows so
I can introduce you?
And of course I said yes. And of course,
of course she said yes. Yeah, of course.
I've always kind of looked at our
story as something bigger than what he
believes. What? I don't believe it's
bigger. It's capital B. Underlined,
bold. It's big.
Partly because Jim at every show he has
the bone marrow registry people right
there ready to sign fold.
And because of the show they
just saw he can get in hundreds.
Um, I know that dozens of people
have gone on to be matches. Oh.
So this was truly the culmination of,
from the moment I signed
up to be on that registry,
this felt like the zenith
of this entire thing.
Mm.
So next night at Texas
Christian University,
packed house Chanel's in the
audience. I was in like the front row
and during the second part of the show,
when Jim goes through the rebirth part,
he stops and he says, guess what?
Everyone that person who saved my life,
she's here.
Okay. He has me walk up on stage.
Proud wins wild.
It's first time in my life
I got a standing ovation
because your [inaudible]. That's why
the magical is crazy. It's because, yes,
yeah.
All of these kids in the audience who are
all pretty much my age as well at that
point are seeing my being onstage as
the quite possibly the biggest proof
they've ever had. That there is a god,
will you will you know? Was
there any part of you that said,
I shouldn't be here? Are you all,
yeah, there was a part of me that felt
a little bit of an imposter,
but for Janelia she says that feeling
was outweighed just by the number of
people that were lining up at the bone
marrow donation table and so the next
time she had a chance she did it again
and again and again.
She's now appeared at the end of the
show around a dozen times all around the
country playing the role of Jim's
personal savior and she says,
the more time she did it,
the more that feeling,
that sort of fraud feeling kept popping
up each time a little bit louder.
Yeah. There's parts of me,
there's little fibers in my
being better like wow, if,
if this is a sign, if there
is a god, I'm a real jerk.
This is such a beautiful and really
literal story being told to me about like,
hey, you know maybe there is a god.
She said she started to feel that like
if she's both perpetuating that story and
refusing it, there's
special place in hell for me
and this is why Janell got in touch with
us because she wanted us to help her
figure out a way to tell a story that
led her way of seeing the world into the
room. Okay. Are you guys,
is everyone there? Hi Jim.
Can you hear us? Yeah, I can hear
you guys. Jenelle can hear me. I can.
How are you? So our producer let,
if Nasser actually started talking to
Jenelle about what exactly she wanted to
do and they decided that we
should just all get in the studio,
Jim and her and all of us and see
if we could hash it out. Okay.
I guess like Jenelle do you want to just
kind of talk through what we've been
thinking?
Oh sure. I can try and if you want
to help me, lot TIF sir. Um, uh,
essentially lot defy and I have been
talking about what would be the best way
for me to kind of tell my
side of the story. Um, yeah,
my side of our story so to speak
without so much of the religious stuff.
Yeah. So when are you
guys gonna do that? Hmm,
maybe I missed the point. I'm sorry.
So do you say we as in like
we are going to [inaudible]
do you have version of that? Well I
thought you could help me. Oh cool.
Well I have no problem kind of just
cause you are so not only a magician
with magic things but also with words
[inaudible] so maybe if we could,
if you could help me. So yeah,
totally.
That's, that's so interesting. My
mind begins to spin and I have a,
so at first we suggested maybe Jenelle
could come out at the end of one of Jim
shows and just read a statement or
something. And Jim said, you know,
that's probably not gonna work. As you
guys know in this world, there's, I mean,
audiences come based upon how things
are marketed and booked. And Jim said,
you know, he has to worry about sort of
as a business, the expectations of his,
of his sponsors and even
the audience who are,
who are looking for a certain thing like
a producer. Cause I'm, I'm totally up.
So we're like, yeah, okay, fair enough.
Maybe we could be like a Q and a
after the show or something like that.
I don't know. I'd have to really like
process it, but I'm totally open to it.
I would always love to
help. Um, Jenelle fig,
I mean help her put it all together
and like, I think though that,
so eventually we landed on a plan. Jim
was going to be doing his show up in St,
cloud, Minnesota and we decided,
well we could just do a show with
him and Jenelle the next night.
So along with producers, Latif Nasser in
any McKeown, we headed up to St. Cloud,
met up with Janell and that night
we went to all go see Jim's show.
It's pretty big venue. There was
probably like a thousand people.
They're all college students and
of course because Juno was there,
uh right after he did the sort
of personal journey back to God.
She's here too. [inaudible]
a bit hard to hear,
but there was literally like a shutter
of energy that went through the crowd at
that moment.
Ladies and gentleman, welcome to this day.
Just as General Jenny come on up here too.
[inaudible]
so yeah,
you're the much better speaker than me.
What I can say is I encourage
all of you taking center.
So Janell just pointed out
that the national bone marrow
registry would be there
that night and she encouraged
everybody to, you know,
sign up and have a chance to save
a life and and do something good.
So please do that or at least consider it.
Then Jim had her show the whole
audience or puzzle piece. Tattoo
[inaudible] only one
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and once Janell had
stepped back off the stage,
before we close, I wanted to
know if I can pray for you.
Do you guys still pray in Minnesota?
All right, so would you
mind, I told you to leave.
I want you to pray this prayer with
me. Just say this in your home.
So Lord Jesus,
two nights I choose to turn
and start living for myself,
my own version of my own
story and I want to trust you.
I don't have all the
answers, but I know you do.
And tonight and by faith I choose to
follow you. Thank you for loving ladies.
Thank you.
In the midst of all of this randomness
that I experienced coming after me for
being jealous, I love him too.
In Jesus mighty name. Amen. And Amen.
And then just before
everybody stepped out,
awesome. This is very good. I'm
going to be here another night.
I'm going to appear that we're
going to be here tomorrow.
Have you guys heard the [inaudible]?
That was about three
people that shout it out.
They're in the audience. I'm just going
to sit. I'm not going to point them out,
but in the audio,
nobody cared.
I'm ready. Man is going to be
holding this forum. [inaudible] now,
Jen is going to touch your side of the
story of what happens is we heard through
this process. All right. All right,
so after the show we actually got a
chance to talk to some of the people from
the audience.
Then hearing the whole three
days, I'm like, oh my God.
That's wow. Oh my gosh. I can't
believe that she was actually here,
here in their rank about it.
I would've been so shocked to
sit right next to her. Yeah,
pretty much everybody was totally floored
by actually getting to see Janell in
person and they all seem to take her
story the way Jim does a visual example,
put a face to this whole thing. So
many things fell in mind where, yeah,
you just have to believe
in my opinion. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. So
[inaudible] the next night.
Good evening, everyone. Welcome.
My name is mark spring, winter night.
Much less fanfare in a much smaller room,
like maybe a hundred people there are.
So with the help of the religious
studies program at St, Cloud University,
hear me okay? Yes, here I am. Oh my
God, we did Janelle's thing. All right.
So I'm Robert [inaudible].
I am one of the cohost of the public
radio program cause they called radio lab.
I want to introduce also,
sorry wheeler who is our managing
editor who's gonna at Sam.
He's going to be adding his
2 cents from times nine.
We're a very democratic show and like
nobody controls anything and everybody
pitches in so, so he will to, uh,
and I want to begin by
just telling you a story.
So we brought Jenelle up
on stage, but you know,
could you just come up here and sit,
I guess, might as well sit here.
We told them her whole story of, you know,
donating and then waiting a
year to find out, you know,
who Jim really was talk,
I had no idea that when
we brought Jim onstage,
I saw Jim the years up,
he talked about, you know,
his whole process of recovery.
Trying to get your bearings.
You talked about how
grateful and thankful he was.
And then we turned back to Janelle. Me,
let's make this a little
more complicated. Sorry.
Could you just run the a m I asked you
like how you felt in that first round and
you, this is what you
told me in the interview,
there was a part of me that felt
a little bit of an impostor.
Well, no, why, why would you use
the word imposture? What is that?
Why did you choose that word?
So that's how we should start getting
into the meat and potatoes of my thoughts.
I think so, yeah.
Part of me is, um,
and at that time especially
thought that I'm up here,
um,
again as this pretty hard and fast proof
or a very compelling narrative for a
lot of people and their faith that
I don't particularly share at all.
Okay. Can I ask a
question? Yeah. Um, but I,
I knowing that you knew
what at that point,
cause we talked about that and I was,
I was very concerned knowing that you,
you know, didn't agree with
what I believe to be true, that,
that you would feel like
you were in that spot.
Okay.
That's why I asked you. Oh, of
course. And I could've declined. Yeah.
But at the same time,
it doesn't make anything different than
the fact that it's still what it is,
you know? Exactly.
I would have done it regardless
of whatever it was. Yeah.
If your whole theme of your show was
how great the Dallas cowboys were and it
got everybody to join the bone marrow
registry, I would have got up there,
cowboys hat. Honestly, Jim,
every time I see your show,
even though I don't it, you know,
adhere to the religious tenants of it,
I still get that feeling and everybody,
all my family, all my friends,
whatever their religious,
even my Muslim friends that
I've told this story get,
do you know that feeling?
And you know what that feeling is,
is a little intangible.
But I think it's something
even a little bigger than
that. Sounds so crappy
to say bigger than Jesus.
That's really blasting miss, but
I can't think of a better way.
What did he, what did you mean?
Can you explain what that means?
Well, you know, um, that
there is good in this universe and
there is good in everybody and it is
regardless of
the goodness is at the top of the list
of you and everything else is follows
your religion and your race and where
you were born and your favorite pizza,
toppings and all of that.
But at the very top is
good with the capital
junior. It's underlined too.
All Right Jim,
in your show you have a
rather gorgeous take on,
on moral relativism. You have
a, a string of bonds, um,
that this idea that being good and doing
no harm and living as ethically as,
you know, how is
satisfying to some people,
but can you review it
isn't really enough. Um,
oh yeah. This is where we,
I mean obviously there's
some disagreement here. Um,
I think that there is good
and I think that there is evil
in this world and I think that people
in and of their own left to their own
vices left on devices. I think
that they struggle with being good.
I think that even on our best
day, I think that we fall short.
And so in hearing her account, you just
say, you just saying thinking what?
That, that, that she's not
[inaudible]
what is, what if, where does she fall?
She, where does this idea lose you?
I don't, I mean, it doesn't lose me. I
think it's phenomenally good. It's not,
not acknowledging as good. I just think
that it's for it, for the Christian.
It's not about being good or
bad. I think, what is it about,
I think it's about, uh, I think it's
about having a relationship with God.
Does that make sense?
That last sentence? I guess it makes
sense at that point, Jim, you know,
he made it clear that he definitely wasn't
condemning Janell because she didn't
have a relationship with God. But then
we took it sort of different approach.
We started talking about the
unlikeliness of this whole story,
which is one of the things that Jim talks
about in his show and so at that point
I decided I should jump in
and I, I say this and I,
I really say this only because it is our
job as a show that when we hear a story
like this, we dig in,
we investigate and we do that from
a frame that really focused on math,
facts, science
and couple of things happen to you
if you happen to be in my position,
you run across stuff like this and I'll
just read from the BIA match website.
A patient's likelihood of finding a
match donor on be the match registry is
estimated to be between 66 and 97% the
chances that you'll find a 10 to 10 match
in the way that Jim and Jenelle were 10
to minute 10 matches is around 50% oh
wait a second year, which I,
that doesn't make sense to do it.
Well it doesn't because a million
people, he, she was the one, yeah.
Let me say that this does not actually
contradict with Jim and Janelle's
experience of it for, for that to
happen to Jim, it is truly staggering.
It is truly, it could be one
in a trillion. And you know,
like the way winning a
lottery has one in a trillion.
That how can it be both one in the can.
Because what happens is if you back up
away from the individual and ask not what
are the chances, that's
what happened to Jen,
but what are the chances that this
would happen to someone somewhere?
It's like there's this,
there's a story about if you're golfing
and you hit a golf ball and it goes
however many hundreds of yards.
I don't play golf so I
don't know how far they go,
but it lands on a blade of grass
and that blade of grass says,
why me?
Why would this golf ball crush me
like this? Which is a valid point.
Uh, I would feel that too. Uh,
but that ball was going to land
on some weight of grass. So you,
it doesn't like there the
why me is still a true thing.
It is a true experience in which there
is a, there is still this difference.
I think, um,
the ball can't point to anything greater
no than the argument alerts behind this
is uh, that these things happen
and it is just chance two places.
The random view accrediting, how
are you going to be able to that,
that you were randomly there and
you were randomly [inaudible]
chosen isn't the bird you were it
that the ball's mercy landed on you.
But I'm not, I also am not coming
at it from just that angle.
I wonder if it was just
the bone marrow transplant.
If it would be people
get that all the time.
I think perhaps the other bits and pieces
of the puzzle maybe help shadow it in,
you know, a little bit for me. Um, and
so I don't know if it's me. It's a,
it's a multilayered cake. I
thought you really don't like this
idea of like in this science version
there is no design and there is no first
cause except the first random event
that sets the thing in motion. Right.
Do you do both?
Could you either of you live with that
version of what just happened to you?
[inaudible]
yeah.
Well that's perfect cause it's exactly
what you talk about in your show with
the, all the different cards
Janelle's referring to a thing in gym
show where he talks about how unlikely any
particular order of cards in a deck is.
And the idea of a particular set of cards
being dealt in a particular way is 52
factorial, which is pretty much
impossible. It is impossible.
It's an impossible number you could
statistically, right, right. But yet you,
the cards and they happen right there.
So this really gets into
just the different viewpoints
on the proverbial deck of
cards and who's dealing them.
Is it in a particular fashion?
And I think that's, you know,
what Jim believes is that there is
a proverbial dealer and I don't,
I guess,
and you agree that that's
pretty much the difference.
Yeah. I mean, having
given thought to that, um,
I believe that, that there
was some sort of, you know,
mind personality [inaudible]
so the, I believe part is where you
is, where you stand. It is. Absolutely.
Yeah. Absolutely it is.
It's faith and [inaudible]
your his savior I guess.
And we saved his life. But
in some way you don't, you,
you haven't. I don't. How do
you worry about this at all?
Yeah, absolutely. And even
right now on this stage,
there's a part of me that in front of all
of you that I'm sure a lot of you were
at the show last night. There
was a part of me that is
afraid of disappointing that I don't
share what you believe to be true.
I mean, you're an entire experience,
pretty much points the Arrow that like,
I'm like an alliteration
of Jesus and your story.
And that's really difficult to reconcile
as someone who doesn't have faith.
And it makes me sad sometimes because I
think it would be a lot easier if I just
believed exactly what you believed.
And I think that I always am very
afraid of letting that be known.
Like I'm super like clammy right now,
just saying it in front
of this many people. Um,
I just feel like people would see
your story and it's so tremendously
compelling. It's unbelievable.
And then see that that last piece of this
little puzzle literally doesn't fit at
all.
I mean, I, I, it's not like I haven't,
I haven't thought about that either. Um,
and how you might feel and I empathize
and I don't know how to answer that.
Yeah. You know, I, I just, I just
want to give you a hug, but yeah,
there's an unconditionality to
how I feel about you that I just,
you can do no wrong in my eyes. Yeah.
Here's the, for you,
the hardest thing I was just trying to
think of how difficult this must be.
You have been, say your life has
been saved by her [inaudible].
She is in effect your savior.
And yet your belief is that
unless she accepts Jesus,
that in some sense she's outside of
grace. And you know, I don't know.
I don't know what you believe
about Hell and heaven,
but that she might be punished.
So what do you do about this weird
contradiction? She's insisting, nope,
not for me. Then you says, oh, this
is the way it is, and oh my gosh,
it's was it, is it hard
for you? No, not at all. Okay.
I'll tell you why. Because
it's not my place to do that.
I'm very sorry to everyone
who listens to this,
whoever feels like they got judged by
Christian cause it's never their place to
do that. And this is where I think most
of the times and everybody listened.
This podcast is placed as kind of
positioned or pigeonholed Christians.
And what they don't understand is that
I'm not commanded to do anything but to
love and to start conversations.
Right? I'm not the one, I'm the,
I'm not the, I'm not the one who was
sent into the world to judge. All right?
But what I, so, so putting
it like that, I know,
I know where you want to go with this.
No, I'm just, this is not
actually an honest question.
You have to love the judge that may
not love the woman who saved your life.
That's hard I think yet. But,
but at the same time, it's, uh, that's,
that's not what I'm s that's
not, that's not my place.
I had to say,
I think we were sort of expecting that
maybe there would be a sharper edge to
the differences between Jim
and Janell. But to be honest,
their conversation that night and,
and their stories started to feel like
almost an allegory for how to move through
the world and hold your differences
but still be one.
Let me just finish this way. Do you
have a sense between the two of you? Um,
because I mean obviously you,
you stay very, very good friends.
I mean that's obvious.
Is there some something that either of
you can say that explains why you can
dignify ugly but emphatically disagree
and still stake such extraordinary close
touch?
I think the idea of humility
and as Jim might even say,
grace
is
absolutely essential no
matter your tenants of belief.
And that's really what's going
to get you through conflict.
So yeah.
And is it because you're in this big
ocean of the world and the two of you or
just little little dots in it and
so whatever you think is still,
you're in the big ocean and there you
are together. Is that the, I think maybe.
Yeah. Yeah. And do you
ever have a bigness thing?
Do you feel small? Do I feel small? Yeah.
I feel tiny humility at it's root word
is it comes from the root as Hump Humus,
which means dirt. Huh?
So when you become
humble, you become there.
And however I can see it now, I can
keep going. I can keep going. You know,
God does with third is he creates
things, but I won't go there.
But you become dirt.
And, um, and I think,
I think where we get hung up
is that we want to be right.
And that hasn't been
brought into the this yet.
You want to be right and right and wrong
are the words right and wrong are our
dead, I think in relationship or deadly
words. I think that saying I'm right,
you're wrong. Um, is, is, it's
not good for relationships.
I think it's like, let's
find, let's find where we,
have you ever said you are right
or you're wrong to her? No.
No one said to him either. I'd
never left a nice place to land.
I think so.
I think we're done. Now. That
doesn't mean we're done. Done.
That means that I'm going to let
these two people introduce the person
at the end of the show. We had the bone
marrow registry people there and uh,
encouraged people sign up and quite
a few dead, I think maybe 20 or so,
but that was pretty much
nothing compared to what gym.
Got It. At the end of this show,
150 people, wait, say that again.
Just like 150 people signing up
right now. Did you count them?
That's our producer Andy
McEwens at least that.
Is this bigger than normal
or I always like this.
This is a little bigger than
normal, I think anytime,
but I'm actually in the show.
It's a little bit better.
So I've been told and what is it? How
are you feeling when you watch this?
It's really overwhelming. Like, yeah,
it kind of makes me want to cry. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean without you,
this wouldn't happen,
right? It's almost too big to think of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
thank you, sir. Sure, no problem.
This piece was reported by Latif Nasser
produced by Annie Mcewen with help from
Bethel hop day and Alex Overington special
thanks to Julie Schmidt with be the
match. And by the way,
they are one of the several bone marrow
registries and says the one that Jim and
Jenelle were connected to
is called be the match.
And if you want to donate while we've
made a special arrangement with them,
all you have to do is go to join
dot B the match.org as capital B,
capital t, capital m one word.
join.be the match.org/radio lab.
And you'll get to a spit swab
thing in the mail. Maybe. Well,
maybe you can save a life. It's
free if you are under 45 so again,
that's join dot B the match.org/radiolab.
Also, thanks to Ginger Galvin,
Bryce Harney and stay true with the
maze after Mark Springer, Kevin Sharp,
Jim Gray, Kelly Larson, and the rest of
the wonderful faculty and staff at St.
Cloud State University in Minnesota.
You can see and hear and
learn more about Jim.
show@whatisthemaize.com that's one
word. What does amaze.com also,
Jim has a book about his
experiences and his, his stories.
That's also on our website, so we want
to go there and look at that. Alright.
I'm chatting with Rod I rubber pro, which.